All day, it's the chita chat time. It's the chita chat time. Chitty chit chat chat. Ooh, Angela, is this our new intro to? We had one. We abandoned it. We did. We did.
You know what? I like the idea that we just cycle in a new one every once in a while. We just in the moment. If someone feels inspired to make up a single. Okay. All right. Should we get started? We should get started.
I did want to say this even last time. I didn't comment on it. Jenna, behind you, I don't know. They're leaves. Are they birds? They're things on the wall. They're fish, I think. They are fish, Sam, yes.
Fish. Oh, yes. They are a series of 3D fish, tiny fish, golden fish. Art. They're all gold. And they are arranged and they're swimming in a circle. And this is the decor for above the fireplace. That you're renting while you're in Chicago.
Is it cold enough? Have you used the fireplace yet? I have not. It is not. wood burning. Oh, okay. But I think it's gas and I think it could work. But no, it's been unseasonably warm here. Oh, really? Okay. As people are telling me, but it just turned cool. So, I don't know. I'm only here one more week. One week. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. We're going into our last weekend of the show. It's crazy. You must have lots of feelings about that. I do. I'm very
excited to get home to my house and my kids and my life there. Right. Angela, I left you a message about this, about how, like, when you have quirks, when you're on location, you know this, Angela. You go on location and you have to live in a place that is not your home, that you don't have a lot of control over. Yeah. Like, I remember this one place I lived, the cutlery drove me absolutely bonkers. I hated it. I hated the cutlery. It was such a little thing, but I hated it.
The knives didn't really cut anything. It drove me nuts. I got home from that, and I remember just like, loving my knives and being like, there you are, little nice that I picked out that I love with all my heart. I didn't even know I loved you so much. Well, here, the quirk is the placement of the light switches. And they drive me absolutely crazy. In order to turn on the light for the kitchen, it's by the front door. That's the only one? Yes. That's the only light for the kitchen. So I repeatedly walk in and then I walk into the kitchen and I realize, oh, dang it.
The light is over the front door. And I have to turn back around. Likewise, once I've lit up the kitchen and I've cooked something and I want to turn off the lights and like maybe sit in front of the TV and watch something while I eat, I have to walk back to the front door. And it's not like it's that far. It's just illogical. It's just odd. It's just I want the light switch for the kitchen to be by the sink.
That's where I want. And if I lived here, I would call an electrician and I would say, will you please put a light switch to the kitchen in the kitchen? I love like kind of like a new place like that because there's always some little delicious treat waiting for you that you didn't think about. Like my friend Betsy is she's got a directing gig in Ireland, right? And so she's got this rental in Ireland right now. She's working on a show there.
And we decided to do a little FaceTime catch up. And as she's talking to us, me and all of our tennis gals, we're all looking at her. And we're like, is that half of a bird behind you? That's a lamp? And she goes, oh, yeah. Yeah, I don't know why. There's a bird thing happening here.
And you guys, the feet of the lamp were like the stork. You know, like the feet. And then the long, skinny legs. And then the poofy butt with all these feathers. And then no head. Just the lamp shade. Is the head the light bulb? Is that where the head would be?
It's just a lamp shade. Yes. That's pretty great. But like, what happened? And you have little, you have gold fish. Fish. And the gold fish. and light switches in a place that I don't love.
Well, there you go. We can't wait for you to come home. We're very excited. I'm excited, too. I have a request. Angela, I brought this up before. Oh, yeah. It's something I need.
It's so, hi. You guys, this is so dorky. But will you please lead to us from your food journal? Oh, I would love that. I have to explain first, you guys. Okay. So Josh and I, you know, we have this cookbook coming out. You can make.
this. And as part of it, we're doing all this press. And New York Magazine reached out to me to do a piece. It's like a five-day food journal for their piece called Grubb Street Diet. Oh, no. Do they know about your journals? Sam, Sam, it pays off. Oh, God. I'm trembling. It's so good. It's so good. And I need it. I like need a whole, you could write a whole book. Yeah. Okay. Please go. Anyway, Josh and I are dividing up some of these press requests because there's a lot of them and I'm so appreciative that people are getting excited about the cookbook, but I said, I'll take the food journal, babe. Okay, so I had to document like basically my day and what I ate for five days and anyway, in like sort of a journal type, whatever genre.
So here we go. I'm just going to read the first day. Read the first day. This comes out October 24th, by the way. put a link in our stories to it. All right. Tuesday, August 16th, 7 a.m. Hi, from a Southwest flight from Chicago to Burbank.
My husband did the early bird check-in thing. We boarded in Group A. He gets very excited about boarding in Group A. He says it's all about getting that overhead space. And let me tell you, we got a sweet spot for our carry-ons. We had a fun but short trip to see my BFF, Jenna Fisher, in the play Ashland Avenue. it was fantastic. She and the entire cast were amazing. We did, however, stay out way too late
last night, and I'm a little bit of a zombie this morning. So I realize this is probably an odd time to start a five-day food journal, but we're stuck on the tarmac with some kind of plain traffic jam, no Wi-Fi, and I brought my laptop, so I thought, why not get this going? Can I stop you right there? Can I just say one of my favorite parts of the Food Journal is that it starts with absolutely no descriptions of food. Yeah. We're 10 minutes into this. There's no food.
Okay. I was counting how many, yeah, counting how many sentences until you mentioned food and then I lost track. Well, well, well, here's the thing. You guys, they just said they wanted it to be slice of life. Okay. So not, not everything is you making a meal. It's about like your process of the day and where you ate, right?
Sometimes you're cooking at home. Sometimes you're going out. Yeah. But listen, if you read all five days, there's lots of meal eating. watching. Josh made a lot of recipes from our cookbook that are so good and I share all about that. And then I do have a lot of snacks. My nickname was Snacks Kinsey for a while. Your nickname was Snacks and Hambone at a certain point in your life? Snacks Kinsey. Oh, Snacks Kinsey. You got to get it right, Sam. Snacks Kinsey and Hambone. Okay. Because I always have snacks, always. Even right now I've got
some snacks. I love it. That is very true, lady. But listen, I know we have been teasing you, but I like genuinely, truly loved this food journal, like as a piece of writing. And I have been doing a ton of reading since I've been in Chicago. And this was one of my favorite things that I have read. Like in a long time, actually, it took me on a journey. It made me think about how food connects us with other people. I mean, the idea of the article is that you're supposed to describe five days of food in your life. But it just, it becomes so much more than that. And it's because you wrote it lady. And it's, I just love seeing five days of your life through your eyes, which is just, it's kind, it's funny, it's detailed, it's entertaining. I just loved it. Well, Jenna,
thank you so much. That is a huge compliment coming from you. You are an avid reader. So I take that as high praise. And I'm excited for everyone to read it. I had a ton of fun. doing this. Josh says maybe, maybe I should write a book called journal entries and other things someday. We'll see. It's going to be great. I'm so excited. I'm hooked. Uh, thanks, you guys. And then Sam, Angela and I need to confront you about something. Uh-oh. I mean, confront sounds a bit sure, yeah. But I did that as like a tease to get people to sort of like, sit up straight. What are they going to say? Sam, do you have a podcast? You have a podcast? You have a podcast? You didn't even tell us about. I mean, I am, I am just like, what? Angela sends me a message. She's like, did you know about
this? I was like, I didn't know about it. Sam, you got to tell your aunties when you get a podcast. I know. Okay, I am in the process of recording that the first episode's almost done. I just announced it. We hadn't been in studio or I would have mentioned it on air. Yeah, it's called Sweet Tooth. It's about my love of candy. The first episode is about the history of M&Ms. But, but to be fair, I saw this clip that you posted. It is about that, maybe, but includes, um, how shall I say your subversive sense of humor. Yes. So there's lots of tangents on the podcast.
Tangents. Yeah. You know we love a tangent. Uh, at one point I call a, uh, a marriage attorney to see if I could legally marry M&Ms like Peewe says to. At one point, I got it. I almost spoke to somebody, but I, I got pretty far up the ranks calling NASA.
I wanted to see if the Challenger still would have exploded if it had a candy shell, like an M&M. Sam, that is so dark. I know. Sam. That is so dark. This is what I'm saying. Like, is it the history of Eminemps?
Oh, we do talk about Eminemes very briefly. Am I going to learn about the Eminem at any point? Yes, you are. Yes, Forest Mars, Sr., the guy who created Eminem's, found Eminem's by watching Civil Revolutionary War, fighting and eating this chocolate that didn't melt in their hands. And then he came back to the U.S. and he said, I can sell that myself.
Wow. Are you sure you want to? That's a big nugget. Mm-hmm. Okay. Yeah. Sweet tooth comes out on Halloween. Oh, it's a perfect time.
Perfect timing. So I basically wanted each hour to be like you're spending an hour in my brain of how my brain works of like thinking of a topic, thinking of a tangent. And now I can't get back to that first topic until I have to know the, answer to this tangent and then we get back to work. Well, the Sam rabbit hole. Yeah, exactly. In the way that Angela's journaling delights me, your brain also delights me.
So I look forward to this. Good. Cassie, I saw that you did an improv festival. Is this right? Really? Did you, you did a festival? Sketch comedy festival? I thought you did.
You would remember. You would remember this detail. How many festivals do you do? Yeah. I'm doing an improv show Friday night, and it is to promote an up-and-coming D&D comedy show that I'm in doing puppetry for. Wait, wait, wait. Doing puppetry.
Don't bury the lead there. Yeah. I love puppets. This is a live stage show? Yeah. Elaborate. Yeah. I don't think I've said this on the podcast, but I'm a quarter Japanese, and I'm part of a comedy group
called Asian A.F, which is all Asian American comedians. And a group of us are doing like a D&D show. And so for the D&D show, there's like a dungeon master. And then each comedian is playing, is developing and playing a character. And I'm playing a warlock. And I pitched doing a puppet because in college I did a lot of puppetry. And I just haven't done it in a long time. So I have like puppets sitting in my closet.
And I have like. So much Cassie lore that you're dropping. It was so many nuggets. I've known you a decade now. You just casually mentioned I did a lot of puppetry in college. Go on, elaborate. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I did a lot of like first age as well.
Do you build the puppet yourself? Yeah, where do the puppets come from? I have friends that are really good at building puppets. I would help them or they'd help me build a puppet, but that's like sewing is not my forte. So it's more like I get a puppet and then create a character off of it. How do you hold the puppet? It's like Jim Henson style.
like a felt puppet and then you use your left hand to operate the arms and then you do the head. That is amazing. It's really cute. Can we hear preview of the voice you use? No. No? No. What? Come on. Come on. I'll send you, I'll send like a clip of me doing the character, but I honestly haven't done the character in so long that I have to like rehearse it and get it to come back to me. I totally respect that and especially if it's part of the puppetry like in you I would love to see it though. I don't like consider myself like a weird puppet tearing purist, but I do feel like I don't do the character unless the puppets like on. I respect that. Yeah. I do a much better sunny voice if sunny is there because I'm
really channeling him. Yeah. It's harder for me to do his voice when I'm just like by myself. Jenna, let me ask you a sunny question. This is open to anybody in the chat with pets. Has Has anybody ever flown with their pet before? Oh, yeah. I used to fly with my cat, Andy, Andy. Sorry. Andy. Andy is how he pronounced it.
And I think he was part frange. I'm not sure about it. It was a little fronch. Yeah. And I've flown with Sunny as well. I've got the carrier over my shoulder. I'm flying home to Milwaukee with Raman for the first time in two weeks. And he does not like his carrier.
He's never been in one. So, like, I was going to ask, did you introduce your cat to the carrier beforehand or like do you have any flying advice did you medicate andy i did not medicate them andy had traveled so much in his carrier from the time he was little you know to and from college with me all the way out to l.A and then i would fly home with him so he was pretty comfortable and sunny just go into the vet and stuff so no i didn't do any kind of like carrier training that's that's a tough one i talk to your vet about it though because okay you know You definitely don't want Raman to be super stressed.
Stressed, yeah. I think that the most stressful part for my pets is that when you go through security, you have to remove them from the carrier and put the carrier through. And then you carry them like through the metal detector thing. And then put them back into the carrier. And one time, Andy bolted. Really? Got loose?
Yep. He got loose. And then, of course, people are trying to be helpful. So they're chasing him. But I'm like, no, no, no. he'll only let me pick him up. Don't chase the cat. So, of course, I got him back, but that was an adventure. Okay. Yikes. Yeah. I was on a plane recently, and there was a lady that had a, the cat was like the long-haired gray, all-gray kind of cat, you know? Oh, sure, yeah. And they were, she had it in the
carrier and was walking down the aisle and the whole way down, you just heard this cat. And it was just like, me, yeah. I was like, oh, buddy. I went to New York four or five years ago. I had a connecting flight both directions. So four total airplanes. I sat next to a dog, all four flights. No. It was the best day of my life. Did you go buy a lottery ticket?
No. Yeah, exactly. It was incredible. One thing, Cassie, your D&D thing made me think of something. My cousin, Wade, shout out to Wade in All-Nee, Texas sent me this this morning. He said, Ange, look what I bought today. He plays Magic the Gathering. Oh, I know about this.
know that there's a like a whole, is it Dwight? Dwight. Yeah, it's like a Dwight series of The Gathering, yeah. I mean, does Rain know this? Look, Jenna, that's a whole. He does know. He knows. Yeah, he, I talked to him about it. Really? Wow. Mm-hmm. Yeah. That's incredible. Oh, guys, speaking of Rain, I have to talk about his movie Code 3. Oh. Yeah, I saw you post on social media about it. It is so good. Like, it's truly wonderful. It is so funny, but it is so earnest and lovely. It is not cynical. I loved it. What's it called again? Code three. Especially if you love the pit. Yeah. Okay. This movie is like what the pit is to like emergency room
doctors and nurses and everything. This is to EMTs. EMTs, yeah. Like they are the, what's the other word for them? Paramedic. Paramedics. Yes. Thank you. And Rain plays a paramedic and you get to see a whole day in a paramedic's life, like a full 24 hours. Yeah. And it is, oh, God, it's so good. And it's like, it's funnier than the pit, but it has that element of the pit where it's just so human. Yeah. So shout out to Rain for that.
It was written by Patrick Pianneza and Christopher Leone and directed by Christopher Leone. And I always just like to shout out the writer and director. Yeah. Great. It's in our cue. And since I'm shouting out movies, guys, here's another. thing. Since I've been in Chicago and my kids have been back in L.A. with Lee going to school. Every evening after I do the play, I come home and I have to kill like 90 minutes while I wind down.
So I have watched so many shows. I have watched so many movies. I never have time for this in L.A. So I'm going to shout out another movie. Broke. I don't know if you've heard of this movie. Stars Wyatt Russell and Auden Thornton. Absolutely again, so charming, so human, beautiful acting. It's about a guy who rides Broncos and like the effect that it's having on his body and everything. So he's like a rodeo cowboy and he's going around and doing the Bronco ride. And what was it called again? It's called Broke. Broke. Okay. And it's written and directed by Carlis Eubank and it's very, very good. Those are my little movie shoutouts. I've also read tons of books. You're sounding a lot like Taylor Swift. Did you see her trailer today? The end of the
Ares Tour, like movie that's coming out? No. There's another movie coming out. I went to her showgirl launch movie thing with my daughter. It's coming out in December and lady, it's all the behind the scenes of how they did the Ares Tour. There's a shot of her. She's taken off all her makeup.
And she's like, well, basically, for me to wind down from that performance, I have to watch like hours of like TV and movies and stuff. Yes. And I thought of you. I was like, well, Jenna and Tate. We have so much in common. There's so much we could talk about. We'll talk about our wind down routine.
You guys should tour together. We really should. Yes, you guys should do a tour together. And you know what? I'll journal about it. And Cassie will do the puppet show and Sam will do a really sort of like, edgy podcast about it. Oh, guys, this was wonderful.
Hey, one more thing before we go. October is Breast Cancer Awareness Month. Yes. I'm realizing that it was one year ago that I revealed my breast cancer diagnosis to the world. And with this anniversary, I've been reflecting a little bit. I want to just take this moment to, again, encourage people to please go do their self-exams, get their mammograms. You can do this test where you kind of enter in all this information about yourself
so that if you're under 40 years old, you might qualify for a mammogram just based on your family history. and that's really important to do too, because in my advocacy work around this, I have met so many women under the age of 40 who are being diagnosed with breast cancer. And so it's not just for us older ladies. It's just really important not to ignore anything. And just in that vein, like get your colonoscopy, do your skin check. Like, just check it all. Because 100% early detection is why I was able to get treated and why I'm now off in Chicago doing a play and living my best life. So for sure, for sure. But yeah, a lot has happened this year. Oh, I guess I can I'll give an update. I finished my Herceptin infusions. I got my port out. Yeah, Jenna,
I was going to say, where are you at now in this journey if you don't mind sharing with us? Sure, yeah. So I'm done with all of the treatment except for the five years of Tamoxifen, which is a hormone blocker. And what that does is it blocks my body from absorbing estrogen. So basically I'm like a woman in menopause in medieval times. Like I don't get any hormonal support. I just have to just white knuckle my way through it. But I've been on it for a year.
Way to go. 20% finished. Nice. I'm tolerating it pretty well. I think I'm tolerating it well because of the weight lifting that I'm doing. Yeah. So if there's a lady out there, right, Sam?
I know we've traded messages about weightlifting. That's all right. And there's any ladies out there who are about to start a Tamoxifen journey or on a Tamoxifen journey. I highly recommend weightlifting. I also recommend acupuncture that has helped my hot flashes so much. Also, I'm sorry to say, avoiding sugar and alcohol has also really helped me with the hot flashes and being really, really strict about my sleep schedule. Like, really sleeping is so important
to me being able to tolerate some of the side effects of the drug. And yeah, I emotionally, emotionally is a whole thing. I forgot about the breast cancer and all of it while I was doing this play. But now that I'm getting ready to come back to L.A., it's on my mind again. I have to go get my next round of scans again, all the checkups, all the doctor's appointments, all the stuff like it happens. It's like I got this break. And I think that's the thing that I've been talking to a lot of women about, which is that when the treatment ends, it doesn't end. Like, there really is no end. You are a breast cancer patient for the rest of your life. You will be monitored for the rest of your life. And also, like, once you've gone to one of those sort of like routine
appointments that you just expect to be like, you did it, you're fine, come back next year. Like, once you've gone to one of those appointments and gotten bad news, it just creates this little part of you that you're like, oh, bad news is possible, at least for me, where it's like, oh, I could have a bad result. And I think I'd just always taken for granted. I don't know. So anyway, I've got a little anxiety there. Sure. But that's my recap, everybody. But I'll tell you the big news. I'm really happy. I'm really
happy. I am really living my best life. And I feel like the whole experience brought me closer to people and closer to what's important to me in life. That's great. I'm really grateful ultimately. So, well, thanks for listening, everybody. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah, of course. Oh, wait, before we go, before we go, Um, Ange, I want to tell people about our idea that we had for an Office Ladies episode that is inspired by Friday Chit Chats. Okay, here it is. Um, we want to do an episode, a full chit chat episode of Office Ladies with a special guest, TBD, and we want to chit chat with you.
We want you guys involved. So we asked Ileana to make a folder for the Office Ladies website called, I believe, chit-chat ideas because we are going to chit-chat off of your suggestions. So not like episode suggestions, but just chit-chat, slice of life, slice of life suggestions. And Angela, you will put a swipe up, right? Yes, I will put a swipe up in our Insta stories. I can't wait to hear from you guys. This is going to be so much fun.
All right. Well, guys, that's our Friday chit-chat. Yeah. Well done. All right. You guys have a great rest of the week. week and I love you. Hi.
See you then. See you later. See you later. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.